i feel like we are so blessed to have
the best support system and the best
family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through
kim kardashian and kanye west just
reunited for the first time
since his controversial political rally
in south carolina
and that twitter storm of since deleted
tweets
about his wife i've seen him go through
a lot i always know his heart a source
tells e.t
kim flew to cody wyoming monday to see
kanye
after weeks of trying to get a hold of
him quote the meeting was
extremely emotional as the couple has a
lot to work through now
and most importantly making sure kanye
is healthy
the source adds that kim is still very
upset with kanye
but knows she needs to focus on him
getting better and plans to do whatever
she can
to get him the help he needs while the
skims designer was in wyoming where the
rapper has been living
the two were seen driving around
together having what appeared to be an
emotional conversation in the car
where kim seemed to be crying their
tear-filled reunion comes one day after
yay made a public apology to his wife on
twitter
for airing their private issues in
public even if my wife were to divorce
me
after this speech she brought north into
the world
even when i didn't want to kanye said in
his apology quote
i did not cover her like she has covered
me to kim i want to say i know i hurt
you
please forgive me thank you for always
being there for me
meanwhile source told et on saturday
that kim and the fam
are happy the 43 year old apologized but
they just want him to get help
kanye said hurtful things to kim and the
family and in time that will heal but
kanye's health
is priority in life what i've learned is
you just kind of have to go with it
on saturday kanye was photographed
arriving at a hospital near his ranch
he reportedly only stayed for 10 minutes
before returning home
a source told et that the fashion
designer went to the hospital because he
was feeling
anxious but he decided that he'd rather
get checked out
at the ranch when he learned that his
vital signs were normal he felt better
my mom saved my life my dad wanted to
abort me
my mom saved my life there would have
been no kanye west
because my dad was too busy of course
all of this comes after kanye delivered
an emotional speech at his presidential
rally earlier this month
where he revealed he and kim talked
about having an abortion
when she was pregnant with her first
child north
she stood up and she protected that
child he later claimed on twitter that
the reality star
and her mom kris jenner were trying to
get a doctor to lock him up
he's just the most genuine person
and you know he might say things that
might get misinterpreted and people
don't see the context behind it
of course kanye has been vocal about his
bipolar disorder in the past
there's some cases of bipolar where
people go low
i'm one that goes high and last
wednesday kim released a statement on
instagram
asking the public to show compassion and
[Music]
empathy
you